investigators in the alec baldwin movie
set shooting are trying to work out how
two people inspected the gun but failed
to notice a live round inside it local
authorities in santa fe county new
mexico are leading the investigation and
have just finished a press conference to
update people on the case 600 items have
been recovered including three guns and
500 rounds of ammunition actor and
producer alec baldwin was practicing for
a scene when he shot and killed film
cinematographer helena hutchins on the
set of the low budget film rust
the director was also injured but
survived so far there are no criminal
charges but plenty of unanswered
questions including how no one noticed
the gun was loaded
that's that's uh what we're trying to
determine um the the
people that inspected or handled the the
firearm when it was loaded uh before it
got to mr baldwin we're interviewing and
there's some follow-up questions that we
need to do so there's uh further
investigation further interviews and uh
and we'll get we're gonna try and
determine exactly how that happened and
uh if they should have known that there
was a live round in that firearm
well let's go through this with karen
helmstead from dw culture welcome uh
karen and so what else did we learn from
that press conference well very little
actually it's really interesting it's
almost actually baffling i mean when you
consider that this is uh nearly a week
ago
the information was pretty sketchy but
no one has been charged and yet no one
has been ruled out absolutely no one on
the set so criminal charges themselves
have not been ruled out we learned that
the gun that alec baldwin was using was
a vintage pistol that did indeed contain
a live lead round
and they've recovered that lead
projectile from the shoulder of the
wounded director joel souza
but the evaluation of these various
ballistics anal analytics analyses and
and forensic evidence seems to be
ongoing and as we heard there or as you
mentioned the investigators have
confirmed this uh seizing of many many
rounds of ammunition from the set which
is
really frankly very bizarre because the
director himself has actually told
investigators that there should be
there's no need for live rounds on his
movie set he wasn't aware that they were
there
so it really remains as we heard to to
be seen
how they got into this gun uh who was
lacked last in contact with the weapon
before the assistant director actually
handed it over to alec baldwin saying
that it was safe
it was a real gun it was not a prop and
it's pretty clear that these
investigations are are really just
beginning let's talk about the the
assistant director that you mentioned
there david halls who who had there's
been a lot of focus on him through in
the last week or so there has indeed um
because we do know and
sort of details have leaked out over the
past few days that he has been the
subject of complaints uh on previous
productions over the past couple of
years in the past it's it's been noted
and complained about that he's
relatively lacks with safety protocols
he doesn't always follow the rules he
tends to push his teams very hard and
sometimes over time
raising sort of questions about the
general safety of staff under his watch
there were apparently also two other
accidental gun discharges on this set
just days before this accident happened
so there are a lot of questions around
why the firearm specialist ms hannah
gutierrez
wasn't on top of what was actually going
into the weapons on her set um if if the
director was under the impression that
things were not
that no live rounds were present and and
of course why the assistant director mr
halls didn't check that weapon one more
time before handing it to mr baldwin and
saying it was a it was a cold gun okay
so we we have this this
press uh conference that that happened
in the last hour or so um
but the investigation is ongoing so yes
i think
well the district attorney uh has said
that it could take weeks and months she
has also mentioned that she likes to be
very thorough i think they're being very
careful about this um they want to make
sure that they collect all of the
forensic evidence they have a crew of i
think around 100 people they they intend
to question and conduct interviews with
every single one of them so that of
course will take time um the fact that
there were a lot of tensions and labor
disputes actually happening on the set
already from the beginning of filming in
early october adds another dimension
that i guess the investigators
definitely don't want to ignore so uh
they they're trying to be thorough and
and being very very cautious with what
they release okay thank you for that
karen karen helmstead from uh dw culture